now it's my turn  well guys your girl finally made it to  midgar  my name is materia hunter and elite  special forces operative for the new  wutai government  will prove to our common enemy that  wutai is not to be trifled with  members of avalanche we got this i'm  back  ah there you are someone's been  expecting you what  took you sorry about that anyway it's  nice to meet you  i'm sonan kasakabe where's clown we lost  him  you what he will be okay though right  well of course he will they're the ones  who blew up the reactors  cool should we say hi  no better not after what they've done  you've got to assume shinra's on their  tail  look a moogle hmm  we gotta help  no freaking way  boss  you guys should probably get moving got  it whatever it is they're planning  you're better off out of it they deserve  what's coming  yeah they do but i'm not your sister  there you are who are these jerks no  clue it just appeared  now let the hunch begin